5,1% c'est là hausse des prix à la
consommation sur un an en France
constaté ce mois-ci par l'INSEE une
inflation moins importante que les mois
précédents mais pas de quoi crier
victoire du côté de nos portefeuilles
après petite commune du Loir-et-Cher on
ne manque pas d'idées pour faire des
économies et depuis plusieurs années
déjà des commandes groupées sont passées
notamment pour les livraisons de fioul
l'idée c'est de bénéficier de rabais
accordée par le fournisseur une démarche
qui prend tout son sens actuellement
Florent Clavel
prêt 300 habitants et championne des
achats groupés
cet après-midi le maire Éric Gouget a
rendez-vous avec Nathalie objectif faire
le point sur les prochains achats
groupés de fuel cet habitant est une
convaincue cette méthode lui permet
d'amortir en partie le choc de
l'inflation
des livraisons à 88 centimes aujourd'hui
on est à 1 euro un euro 20 c'est c'est
énorme et l'achat participatif comme ça
ça nous permet quand même de faire une
petite une petite économie non
négligeable d'autant plus qu'on fait
plusieurs fois le pour ceux qui font
plusieurs fois le plein de la cuve
6 à 8 centimes d'économies par litre
pour une cuve de 1500 litres de fioul
comme celle de Nathalie c'est 120 euros
de moins sur la facture finale plus de
10 ans maintenant que la commune a lancé
les achats groupés le principe des
habitants mutualise leur commande auprès
d'un même professionnel pour obtenir des
tarifs préférentiels on est livré dans
les quelques jours qui suivent avec un
moyen long à un montant qui est réduit
c'est ça qui fait le fait d'un achat
groupé pour moi je vois que c'est un
avenir pas que pour le fioul mais
beaucoup de d'autres choses et
d'ailleurs Éric Gouget a de la suite
dans les idées il nous emmène voir
Bernard un habitant depuis longtemps
adepte du compostage et il convient
profiter d'une prochaine commande
groupée de Bach pour changer le sien on
aura la possibilité d'avoir un nouveau
composteur avec un prix regroupé dans la
commune donc et bien on est partant bien
sûr c'est ça la commune c'est l'intérêt
collectif qui prime
et je trouve que c'est une bonne
initiative à chaque commande groupée ce
sont une quinzaine de foyers qui en
profitent mais aussi la commune plus de
300 euros économiser sur sa propre
facture de fioul